[Music]
so yes and we speak about p.m. - I'm the
first auto-off p.m. - so I will begin by
a presentation about me so I'm a CEO and
funder at key metrics the monitoring
solution built on top of TM - I'm the
first author of PM - that couldn't be
like so big without all the contributors
that made this project better and
full-stack JavaScript developer and I'm
technologists so my app is ready I
develop my application now I need to
purchase in production but deploying to
production is complex there are a lot of
parameters to take into account like on
my application only used like of 10% of
my resources on my on my servers my app
is leaking memory why why the server
went out of memory a lot of question
come to comes to mind when you need to
deploy your application so this is a
this is exactly why I built p.m. - three
years ago so what is p.m. 2 p.m. - is a
production application manager for
Nadia's is dedicated from the GS but you
can manage other software's with p.m. -
it comes with a built in load balancer
guarantees a time and help you manage
your processes so how are your
application before using p.m. - so it's
a bit messy you will use like a lot of
different software you may use like some
UNIX built-in process manager that are
not very well fitted for node.js
applications and so on and also use PM -
you will have like a structured way of
deploying your application you will have
like a global overview you will be able
to use all the resources on the same
server and do a lot of things with it
so p.m. - so it helps you manage and
optimize all the resources are used by
your applications it will also help you
to manage your software from the
usability side
log management deployment and also comes
with the
module feature that allows you to extend
the capabilities of PMT so just some
figures about about the software we have
more than 10,000 stars and github more
than 2 million downloads the project is
like the eighty sixth most popular
JavaScript project on github there are
more than 2,500 commits more than 120
contributors and more than 750 tests so
tests are very important for pm2 because
like PM 2 is entirely built on nodejs on
javascript and we wanted really to
provide a quality software for
production application this is why we we
built a lot of tests we do like almost a
test drive and development across like
five different node.js version from not
GS 0.10 to to the 5.0 so this is like
this is like the evolution of the
projects in the beginning we can see
that an open source project like get a
lot of contributors and like that
contributors that participate to all
part of this software so yes this slide
is mainly to to say thank you to all the
contributors that made the software
better that helped us to solve issues
that build like features and and and
everything so you can see there are a
lot these like is a map of downloads of
p.m. to in real time so it shows you
where p.m. to has been deluded in a real
time in the student this global every
time someone installed p.m. to it does
like a ping on our server we we
translate this this IP address into GPS
coordinates and we put this on this map
this map is inspired from the trunk v
and quite nice we have also large
company already using our software
paypal into eBay Bloomberg sauce West on
the edge P Morgan and so on maybe the
party also
and we are very proud that this company
is a use of software in production in a
lot of servers so now we let let's just
use about p.m. - I will cover all the
aspects from the installation to process
management to monitoring and so on so
first installation of PM 2 is very easy
PM 2 is still on the table the source
code is hosted on github and you can
install it from NPM so you just need to
do NPM install PM 2 - G and you will be
you will have this this software
available from the command line so now
setup is required once you've installed
p.m. - once you launch it it will
directly pop all the files we configure
it heals itself and so on but you can
add some other features like if you want
to have like a cleaner setup of p.m. -
you can do p.m. to completion install
that will help you when you have to
manage a lot of processes when you might
actually to processes that has different
names and and it helps you it will to
complete all these commands and you ever
saw I came to startup that allows you to
generate the startup script so if your
server crash and you get restarted it
will like respond all the processes that
was already launched before the crash
open so Lansing up
sorry jet lag so launching apps so
launching a node.js application is very
easy like all the commands of PM 2 are
very easy to use you can go like very in
a very advanced you can use PM to in a
very advanced way but all the comments
are very simply simplistic to use them
so p.m. to start my node.js application
and we put your application in
background will under the logs will
monitor it and it will auto restart the
application in case of crash or bad
behavior from the application PM 2 is
like dedicated phone RGS but but behind
the scene it's only like oh [ __ ] phone
kind of simple simple [ __ ] so you can
start and kind of script if you need
like to start with a bash script for
example you do p.m. to start script that
Sh there is like a kind of ash table
that do like mapping like yo this is
like the SH extension so it's like a
bash creep and it will start it but if
you need to declare or your interpreter
you do like p.m. to start my application
Python - - interpreter and you can put
the interpreter so you can set the right
interpreter to start the application and
after you can act on your processes so
as it's a process manager there are like
some basic commands like to restart the
application to delete the application to
stop it and so on so if you develop I
came across service application and
let's say that you have like one service
that is sending emails and that is right
now spamming a lot of your user you just
do like p.m. to stop my my my service
that send emails and after it will be
stopped so now the cluster mode so as
you know JavaScript is like mono sweetie
language so basically you will have all
your CPUs that will not do anything and
only one CPU will do all the job so
that's not the best thing because after
your application gets overloaded and can
crash
so this is not the best thing
so while using the cluster mode so as
you know JavaScript is Monas with the
language so it will only use one thread
of our one thread one car on your
computer and by using p.m. 2 p.m. 2 we
duplicate your application to use all
the resources on your computer so once
so all the CPUs will be will be loaded
we dropped and you will be able to
enhance the performance of your
application and so the application needs
to be stateless if you want to use the
cluster mode so it means that doesn't
stop any like a local variable in the
same process like all the variables need
to be like shared for example like
sessions and stuff like that so you need
to use like radius or any other kind of
database to share the states between
your processes so otherwise it's very
simple to start an application in
cluster model you just do p.m. to start
my node.js application - II and the
number of instances if you put 0 it will
auto-detect the number of CPUs and we
duplicate the number of application
depending on the number of CPUs but you
can also declare your own number for
example if you have like a processor CPU
with 8 cores you can say I only want
like 7 CPUs to be used and one CPU that
do like something else like for the
system Oh so after you as the PM 2 is
writing a node.js we are tightly linked
to no GS so we can offer like more
advanced feature so for example the
cluster or future and also like for
managing your application we we offer
reload without downtime so you do p.m.
to reload the name of your application
this will for example if you were if you
already starts it for application in
cluster mode and you do reload it will
pop up for new processes we wait that
the for all processes finish - to
process their work and the new one will
replace the old one so you will not lose
any queries so it's like seamless for
your users and you can update your code
very easily without any don't
after there is the graceful reload
feature that will send the Steindl to
your processor to say okay you are going
to be killed so finish all your your
work or close all the database
connections and so on and after you do
like you process that exit and it will
exit the application and the new one
will replace the old one and after you
have two scalar well this is like a
nifty feature that just like to scale up
or scale it down the number of processes
so if you do like p.m. to scale my up my
API 8 it will like to whip up eight
processes if you do too it will scale
down all your processes and so now
inspecting applications so once you
start your applications it's very useful
to have some information about the
listing of your processes the CPU usage
memory usage and so on so there are some
comments that updating on p.m. 2 p.m. to
list that will simply list all the
processes that are launched so you can
see like the name of your application
the process ID the mode that the script
has been launched on the PID the status
the number of restart app time memory
and all this or key key metrics here
information know so for example you can
see on this list that there is like the
first script is like it's a bash script
and you can see that the mode is fork so
because it's like a bash script it's a
simple [ __ ] but the other application
are like no GS application so they are
all launched on cluster mode after you
can monitor on the CPU and memory usage
you just need to do PM to monitor and in
your terminal it will like pop like
interface built on town caps to see you
in a real-time all your processes are
behaving so you can track this blue
memory usage or feature of your
applications
and you can also get more information
about your processes you just do p.m. to
show the name the name of my application
or JIT and you can get different
transformations so for example on the
top of the screenshot you can see like
the statues name ID the logs it goes
like the logs when you start an
application with p.m. - we split the
logs in two files like a files - to get
like all the error output and one order
to get only the standard output you can
see the PID path the mode that the mode
on which your application has been
started on if there is like the watch
and a reload feature because there is
like this feature on a p.m. - that
allows you to when you start an
application - we start offer to reload
your application when there is a fight
that is changed so it's it can be useful
for staging or development environment
so you have all this metadata on the on
the first on the top of this screenshot
after you can have like some information
about the revision control metadata so
you can see which revision control has
been used whereas this is where the
repository of your application you get
your route data and and the probes value
so the last part on the screen you can
see that there are like some matrix so
basically you can use the PMX library
that allows you to track variable of all
the time in real time from your code so
for example you can track the number of
users can exceed the number of WebSocket
connections you just need to do like
it's very simple to use you just need to
do this to use this library to expose
some variables so you can track their
values without link to do we are
continue after we help developers and
developed by on managing logs so to
display logs in real time just to PM to
logs and you will see like all the logs
in real time you can declare the name of
the application we also offer the PM to
flourish command that will alike just
empty all your logs it can be useful if
your applications through a lot of logs
every seconds and so on and you can
reload the
so if you use like log rotates you can
use PM to really lock so it will like
refresh all the logs the log files so
now organizing applications so if you
build your application in the micro
service where you split your monolithic
application into small services it can
be quite painful to start all the
application with all their options on oh
it should be a so the environment
variable the name of your application
the number of instances you want the the
watch if the application will be
restarted on like owners on a certain
result of memory the argument and some
if you if you have a lot of application
can be quite ugly to manage it over the
time so this is why we have this feature
it's like the JSON declaration so
basically you will have like your JSON
file it can be like in your package the
JSON or it can be like an independent
file where you can declare DBA if you
are and the option of each of your
application of your core service
software so like let's say this one like
this is like I call it ecosystem dot
JSON so we have three applications and
you can see that each application has
different parameters so it's very useful
when you need to a manage an application
with lot of services communicating each
other on the same server and after it's
seamless to use like JSON declaration so
this is like I call it ecosystems ojisan
so after if you want to start all this
application you just do p.m. to start
ecosystem that JSON and it will pop up
all your process ISM and it will be you
will be able to list them and and do all
the comments that are useful for other
OGS application after you can do we stop
p.m. to restart ecosystem the JSON and
you can stop it otherwise
so deployment system so I use it a lot
it's like a picture so basically we
embedded a simple bash script from TG
it's like a very simple way to deploy
application so basically I think that
that developers should be able to manage
themselves the lifecycle of their
application they should not ask to like
the sysadmin our son to deploy the new
the new application because like the
developer need to be able to deploy a
specific version on on one server to see
how it behaves on production and so on
so that's why we published
we built this deployment system in 2
p.m. - so you just take the previous
file that was declaring each of your
application into the echo standard JSON
and you will add the deploy part on the
deploy part you will have all your
environments so for example in this in
this screenshot you can see the
production environment that that that
must be that that has like multiple
earths so you can see that this the
production environment would deploy the
code in this free host and after there
is the staging of arraignment so in
these two to two parts you can declare
out front option which which what is the
git repository that must deploy the pass
deposit deploy comment so for example if
I type in my code here it will run an
NPM install to install all the modules
that if I have if I have added some
modules on my package or JSON
it will start or restart all the
processes that are cloud into the same
phylum with the environment you want and
so on and you can also declare the
environment variable that must be
injected into your application as you
can see in the staging part where there
is like the environment and there is not
there should be staging ok
after the commands are very easy so once
you have this file and you have all the
authorization you have to make sure that
your target servers as like the
authorization to like the clones and and
all these commands you can do p.m. to
deploy my
my configuration file on the environment
and setup so basically it we go to your
server to your remote server we quit all
the the files that are needed we treat
like a deployment file so we'll be able
to track your deployment of all the time
and after unsuited that you you can
update your remote application for
easily so you just do p.m. to deploy
ecosystem design production and we look
at the production part on your ecosystem
file and with a choke codon and if you
deployed like a wrong version or
something like that you can revert to
the end - deployment so p.m. to deploy
ecosystem prediction revert and all many
deployments you want to go back to
rollback
so modules so modules is like a new
feature on human on p.m. - so as you see
there are already some the more
important features that are embedded in
p.m. - from the deployment the
application declaration from the
monitoring feature and so on and now we
do not want to make your p.m. to Blues
either so we don't want to put too many
features on the software so that's why
now we built a module system so it's
like an obvious application that can do
many things that can extend the PM 2
features how it can be a standalone
software or it can be like a monitoring
module so what is the module so it's an
application that extend the PM 2
capabilities because there are like
there is the API on p.m. - so you can
interact with p.m. - programmatically
you just need to put it on your package
- Jason after you can call p.m. two
points tart the name of my file you can
pass the option you want like the JSON
I'll show you before as a parameter it
can be a worker process providing an API
so in the future it would be interesting
like because micro services like a real
trend so in the future it's not I see
that that it would not be like only
library that you
in Seoul from NPM library that you can
interact in your on your with your coder
but it could be like also processes so
you could be able to install like
services that that do like all
authorization and that expose an API
that you can use in another processor so
you could like install different modules
that can do like different jobs for your
application I can be a totally
independent software for example you can
do like p.m. to install cinavia
and you will have like a private and PM
repository or PM to install PM to SMTP
and you will have like SMTP server in
the developed in Nadya's a lot of other
things so basically the command is
simple PM to install my module name the
module name is like the name it's a name
of a module on the NPM repository so you
cannot install any library you cannot do
well like PM to install Express doesn't
makes any sense
it should be like an application that is
configured in a way that can be run in
standalone way so when you do this
PM to install my mojo it gets the module
from NPM it will start it and it will
keep it alive forever after managing
module is like simple PM to install my
module if you want to win install it PM
2 and install and you can configure your
modules so you can put like different
configuration variable that can be
operated by p.m. - so you do PM to set
the name of my module and the name of my
attribute and the new value that you
want to be used in your on your new
software so I will just show you some
modules that we already developed so for
example tulip rotates all the logs of
your file you just do p.m. to install
p.m. to block rotate and this software
we connect to p.m. - we list all the
processes will look at which files are
opened and which file are like being
writing on and it will check if it not
exceed like a certain amount of disk
space or if it doesn't like it sit like
one week and so on and it will
Metiria will log rotate all your final
so built-in you just do came to install
PM to lock rotate and your your audio
file or your log files will be rotated
after there is like this PM to web shell
so PM to web shell doesn't walk on the
no GS 4 & 5 because like behind the
scene behind PM to web shell there is
like TT yjs that is a way to expose the
web shell from your browser so I just
made this proof of concept so if you do
PM to install PM to web channel you will
have a fully capable terminal in your
browser so it means that you can use
Emacs you can use vim you can use H top
you can use anything you want like like
on windows and so on it looks like this
so you just install this module and
after you will be able to connect in
localhost or from remote into a PM to
web shell and you love this terminal for
your capable after you can configure
some things as I showed you before there
is like the configuration system so far
going for example I can do p.m. to set
p.m. to web shell as GPS through true
and it will expose this web shala
in a HTTP HTTP protocol so I do I do not
advise you to use this this module in
production servers on because I can be a
bit risky but it's a nice pull of
concept so to write your own module it's
very simple you just do if you installed
the last test PM 2 version you have
moderns do 0.15 version of p.m. - you
have the comment came to module generate
that will create a sample module that
you can directly publish so after you go
to this folder you do PM to module
publish it we do like npm publish and it
will do a git bash and after you will be
able to say 21 ok install this module so
for example could be like a chat so you
could do like p.m. to install p.m. to
chat for example and you will have like
your chat
could be like SMTP server Daniel's
anything anything you want and the
official motor repositories is p.m. to
either so there are already more than 20
modules so there are only three module
like acting as a standalone processes
and the other modules are like module
that can interact with a different part
of your infrastructure so for example
there are modules that that connect to
your radius database that connect to
your MongoDB database to your values to
your coach DB or anything else and after
you can get the matrix and you can also
act on them so yes monitoring with key
metrics so basically we built our key
metrics the solution key metrics on top
of p.m. to so if you already use p.m. to
its stimulus to integrate two key
metrics and you can do like the basic
monitoring features and you can you can
like track a lot of things with key
metrics so it looked like this so you
have like a listing of all the processes
are on your server and give you a global
overview of all your application in real
time it's like a unique product and we
saw some computer trials coming the more
and more so that's good so thank you
thank you thank you and the slides are
available on you wanna have some
questions for Alexander and PM to thank
you for creating p.m. to using PMT in
production server now but there's one
thing that I'm still thinking about
whether fully using PM 2 is do you have
any docker support by default yes now
I'm using docker but then I'm because of
the foreground mode and stuff some
problem with p.m. to switch back to use
NPM
what's your view and on a support on
docker so we we have some
docker containers that are like able to
run TM 2 so PM 2 is always useful when
you use docker because it can it embed
like the cluster or module
cluster mode and so it it it allows you
to do like all this optimization about
the resources usage and sure I should do
like medomak documentation about docker
but we have really like some docker fire
and I will make like a page on our
official documentation to explain how to
use p.m. to in the best way with dr.
right sorry this is not a good question
except what's the visualization what how
did you do the visualization the slides
it's really cool the globe the globe
it's open source project I I hacked I
don't remember exactly which
repositories but it's someone that that
that built like that we produced like
the same dashboard than in the movie
Tron so there is like this entire
dashboard you can see on the Tron movie
that you did like in JavaScript and I
just took like the map and I acted so
totally the web like a different result
except the monitor the memory memory
usage is there any other additional
memory feature such like hip Tom or
snapshot so yes basically you have like
also the max memory we load maximum
which top commander that allows you if
you use like for example all the socket
IO version that was leaking before and
you cannot upgrade this library you can
use this max memory we stopped that will
monitor the memory usage and that will
reload your application in case of this
result being like reached so you can set
like limits on the memory usage after
for the if dump and
it dump and then CPU dump and so on you
need to use to need to use the key
matrix or a commercial solution to get
these features so you mean we can also
add extra event when the leaking events
happened right yes
max memory restarts yes it's a bit like
Missy but you can see like on the first
line max memory restart and I can put
the memory the memory limit of my
application and it will not do restart
it not doesn't do like a restart it does
like a reload if it's an RGS application
so it will be like seamless to be
reloaded like if your application which
is memory limit it will be seamless like
so it's not like very clean way to under
the memory leaks but sometimes you
cannot do like in the other ways thank
you as far as I know like no J's the
cluster module allows you to secure like
never connections bypassing the UDS
socket to another process so does p.m.
who does it differently so you mean like
you could like use just the cluster
module to do so basically yes you can do
you can just use the cluster module if
you want to use all these views so first
thing is that I think that's not the
developer job to do all these things and
the PM to does much more than just like
clustering your application it adds some
features like the reload like the
graceful willow that are like critical
features of production applications so
sure you can use the cluster mode
crystal module by yourself
but if you use PM 2 it will be much more
cleaner we work like spheres on on the
integration of the crystal mode in
Panaji application so basically yeah
it's battle Alton all right Thank You
Alexander thank you
[Music]
[Music]